so i really hate that i was right about
this but i was right about this donald
trump and his fda
chairman stephen hahn dramatically
and irresponsibly over hyped and
oversold
their announcement about convalescent
plasma
as a coronavirus treatment and stephen
hahn is now admitting it and
of course it really shouldn't surprise
any of us because they've been over
hyping
everything all along going all the way
back to hydroxychloroquine
months ago now i told you when donald
trump held
this completely belligerent unhinged
event on sunday
promoted on saturday as a huge
announcement about coronavirus treatment
the announcement was the fda has issued
an emergency use authorization
for convalescent plasma this was
suspicious convalescent plasma
is a procedure it's a transfusion
of plasma from people who have recovered
from coronavirus the idea being that
transfusing their plasma
into people suffering from the virus
could be
an effective treatment now the reason
that it was suspicious from the get-go
was because there was nothing new about
convalescent plasma so donald trump
making a big announcement and trying to
pat himself on the back as if this is an
achievement
for him or for his administration that
didn't make sense and that was where i
started to think there's something a
little bit fishy going on here and if
you've been following coronavirus for
months the way we have you would know
that convalescent plasma transfusions
have been a
potential treatment for coronavirus for
uh months
around the world uh i have uh relatives
in argentina
who have coronavirus and um six weeks
ago
the possibility of giving them a
convalescent plasma
plasma transfusion if they became sicker
was a possibility it has nothing to do
with donald trump
and so really the announcement was
the fda is issuing an emergency eu
use authorization the announcement was
not really we now can do this thing
called convalescent plasma transfusions
it was we're going to change the for
the infrastructure from being able to do
the convalescent plasma
within a randomized controlled trial to
doing it
under an emergency use authorization and
that
did not seem like a particularly good
idea for the reasons i told you on
sunday
and on monday including that
it may start to be given to patients who
are less sick and don't actually
need something because they would
recover naturally
and there are risks including lung
injury and other potential problems with
these convalescent plasma transfusions
also giving uh
when you have an rct a randomly
controlled randomized controlled trial
you're really zeroing out confounding
factors
to try to focus in on
what was the effect of the convalescent
plasma
and when you do an eua and you start
giving the treatment to more people
including people who were going to
recover anyway
it can falsely or deceptively
incorrectly make the treatment seem more
effective than it is okay i told you all
of that on monday
well stephen hahn the fda's director
stephen hahn
has now conceded that yes it's true
he exaggerated the effectiveness of the
treatment on sunday
he doesn't even try to hide it he
tweeted at the end of a series of tweets
quote
i have been criticized for remarks i
made sunday night about the benefits of
convalescent plasma
the criticism is entirely justified
what i should have said better is that
the data show
a relative risk reduction and not
an absolute risk reduction
this was totally obvious all along
and trump's sunday stunt was merely a
stunt to try
to take credit for something that number
one has nothing to do with him
whatsoever anyway
and number two shock is not the miracle
that they claim
it is now uh utter
i guess okay let me let me do this han
also
went into some garbage math on sunday on
sunday
hans said the drug appears con or
convalescent plasma treatment
appears to lower mortality by 35 percent
so he said for every 100 people who get
the virus it saves 35 people
that's insane okay now i i has
the reason i'm hesitating is the math is
so stupid that i don't know if it's
patronizing to even do this but i think
it's worth putting on the record
the death rate of coronavirus appears to
be about 0.8 percent
if you account for you know all all all
cases
not a case fatality rate but a death
rate let's call it one percent
what that means is that for every
hundred people who get coronavirus you
would expect one to die one percent
death rate
so if convalescent plasma reduces
mortality by 35 percent
if a thousand people get the virus you
would expect
that 10 would die one percent and
convalescent plasma would potentially
save
three or four people right if it's 35
it's 3.5 people per thousand that it
would save
based on a one percent mortality rate
now i want to be really clear
if that's true that's important that's
significant that's not nothing
those numbers are shaky and it's not
clear that that's what it is
but the press release from the fda
containing these claims
was clearly a propaganda document
written by the white house
and when han maybe he misstated and
said from every 100 people that get it
this saves 35
from every 100 people that get it you
only expect one to die so how could it
save
35 when you only expect one to die the
tragic thing is
and if people get why this math is
garbage i apologize for going through
that
the tragic thing is that for many of us
maybe it's obvious
but so many people are still falling for
this stuff um
and and that's uh that's the real
tragedy here you know
dexamethasone tested globally available
globally for months
donald trump takes credit for it as one
of the therapeutics that his
administration has moved forward they
haven't done a damn thing about it
remdessevier tested globally available
globally for months
part of randomized controlled trials all
over the country
trump tries to take credit if it's
something that his administration did
dozens of vaccines under development
many aren't even american
companies developing the vaccines we the
vaccine that ends up being the vaccine
might end up being from oxford
university in the uk
trump takes credit in advance under his
operation warp speed they are lying all
the time
and what i fear is that it will work i
still continue to think it is very
likely that we get an announcement about
we've got a vaccine it's good to go
around october 15th won't be available
right away not to many people
uh and donald trump will take credit and
it'll shift one or two percent of the
vote
and that'll get him re-elected this
fundamentally
is going to be a situation that is dealt
with by doctors
and by public health in the united
states and around the world and it's
going to be dealt with
despite donald trump not thanks to him
and trump trying to
claim heroic credit by saying we funded
production of vaccine doses
in advance that's great multiple
countries are doing that
any sane leader would do that it would
be a
an injustice not to do that to start
producing
vaccine doses in advance common tactic
has nothing to do with trump
republicans and trump are trying to
create the illusion
that their leadership has saved the day
in reality there hasn't been leadership
and as far as having to walk back
you know the plasma stuff um the damage
is already done
way more people see the headline than
see the correction
this is the mo of the trump
administration you put out some
hyperbole up front
people see it they integrate it later
you correct it stephen hahn says you
know i did oversell it a little bit
very few people see it and it's too late
anyway it's typical
it's a common strategy and it's exactly
what they're doing
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience
25 off your first order
this has been a game changer for me this
is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors i
have blood orange which i love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize when we're
dehydrated a lot of the time and
it's become a really a great part of my
daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think
you never fully understand this until
you use hydrant for the first time
i get a great a boost of energy when i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets twenty five
percent off your first order
when you go to drink hydrant dot com
slash
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video